la légion d'honneur c'est pas rien c'est
la république qui honore les gens qui se
sont distingués dans leur exemplarité
leur intégrité leur humanisme vendredi
une promotion exceptionnelle de la
légion d'honneur et de l'ordre national
du mérite à récompenser des centaines de
personnes engagées depuis des mois
contre le coc vide 19 médecins ou
directeurs d'hôpital épidémiologistes
responsable d'epa d'infirmières chef
d'entreprise
toutes ces personnes ont fait preuve
d'un engagement particulier selon la
grande chancellerie
sauf que parmi les méritants en retrouve
des personnalités disons controversé en
fait pas mal de personnes qui ont
sagement suivi la ligne gouvernementale
durant le tout début de l'épidémie de
kobe de 19 à une époque où l'on se
sentait que le gouvernement ne savais
pas vraiment ce qu'il comptait faire ni
comment gérer une situation de crise
sanitaire sans précédent pour garder la
confiance des français à l'époque il
fallait des experts prêts à défendre la
ligne gouvernementale coûte que coûte
aussi indécise soit elle martelé sur les
plateaux télé que le gouvernement savait
ce qu'il faisait
quitte à changer de version plusieurs
fois l'infectiologue karine lacombe fait
partie de ces personnalités
elle a été nommée chevalier de la légion
d'honneur mais excusez moi pour quel
motif
en quoi s'est elle distinguée par son
exemplarité ou son intégrité en assurant
le 17 mars 2020 sur le plateau de david
pujadas que les masques étaient inutiles
qui en disant complètement le contraire
de semaine après en affirmant que les
hôpitaux ne manquait pas de masque alors
que c'était faux en faisant ensuite
ouvertement la promotion d'un médicament
leur md y virent censé être efficace
contre le courant n'a virus tout en
omettant de déclarer ses relations
étroites avec le laboratoire
pharmaceutique américain gilead a il
faut dire que l'europe en a commandé du
raimeux des vizirs 500 mille doses avant
même que son éventuelle efficacité soit
prouvée finalement l'om est a reconnu le
rem des vizirs comme étant non efficace
mais elle a en plus fait savoir que ce
médicament pouvait être dangereux
pourquoi en faire la promotion alors
conflit d'intérêts c'est exactement ce
qu'on explique de façon régulière plus
on est impliqué dans la recherche plus
on est en lien avec les industriels qui
travaillent sur ce sujet et plus on est
connu plus on participe à des congrès
des études donc plus on a des liens
d'intérêts mais il ne faut pas confondre
ses liens d'intérêt avec des conflits
d'intérêts ce qui est sûr c'est que
karine lacombe est resté ultra fidèle au
gouvernement
elle est donc de ce fait récompensé pour
son intégrité
mais il n'ya pas que la légion d'honneur
qui permet aux monarques de remercier
ses laquais on a aussi les nominations
agnès buzyn se voit nommé halo oms à
genève alors même qu'elle expliquait en
janvier 2020 qu'il n'y avait aucun
risque d'importation du virus de chine
encore un bel exemple d'une personnalité
qui a suivi la ligne de communication du
gouvernement jusqu'au bout le professeur
yazdan yazdanpanah gastro entérologue
membre du conseil scientifique sur le
colis de 19 et surtout proche de grands
groupes pharmaceutiques dont gilead lui
a été nommé par le gouvernement à la
tête de la nouvelle agence de recherche
sur les maladies infectieuses
ben voyons ses liens étroits avec de
grands laboratoires pharmaceutiques ne
sont plus un secret il a fait partie des
différents comités et conseils de
plusieurs d'entre eux johnson and
johnson vivable vie msd father janssen
bms gilead entre 2014 et 2019
ils auraient ainsi perçu environ 96
mille euros de groupes privés
donc voilà on a comme l'impression que
le roi remercie ses amis en leur
renvoyant l'ascenseur
en revanche il faut pas trop pousser le
bouchon on a beau avoir l'oreille
attentive du président si on commence à
un peu trop le contredire la friandise
risque d'être rangé dans le tiroir
il semblerait que ce soit ce qui s'est
passé avec philippe juvin le professeur
chef des urgences de l'hôpital européen
georges pompidou à paris
membre du parti des républicains et
figure régulièrement invitée sur les
plateaux télé depuis le début de la
crise a pourtant bien reçu un appel à
figurer parmi les personnes décorées
pour leur investissement dans la lutte
contre l'épidémie
emmanuel macron et lui ont dialogué
régulièrement durant la première vague
de la crise sauf que philippe juvin
s'est récemment montré un peu trop
critique dans un ouvrage paru courant
décembre
il écrit on nous a menti avec un peu on
a tenu des discours contradictoires
on a fait des promesses puis on les a
trahis certes personne n'a été dupe
longtemps mais comment poursuivre les
efforts quand le lien de confiance est
rompu
et devinez
qui n'aura pas son sucre